Bonjour! Avant de commencer ce nouvel épisode
de Gentes Dames Badass je tiens à vous signaler
que la femme dont je vais vous parler n'a
pas été choisie au hasard.
Elle fait partie des nombreuses femmes citées
dans le jeu de société féministe «Bad
Bitches Only», dont je vous parlerai plus
amplement en fin d'épisode.
Et oui, ceci est un placement de produit.
Rosalind Franklin est responsable d'avancées
majeures dans les domaine de la chimie du
charbon, de la structure des virus et de la
structure de l'ADN.
Elle est à l'origine de la découverte de
la structure à double hélice de l'ADN qui
aurait pu lui valoir un prix Nobel et une
reconnaissance mondiale...
Mais les choses se sont passées un peu différemment,
et on va voir pourquoi.
Franklin est née en 1920 à Londres, dans
une famille juive bourgeoise et aisée.
Le milieu dans lequel elle grandit est attaché
aux traditions: les filles y sont instruites,
mais sont destinées à se marier et à participer
à des œuvres de charité...
Certainement pas de travailler.
Ses parents semblent cependant montrer peu
de résistance à son envie d'étudier les
sciences.
Elle montre très tôt des prédispositions
pour les mathématiques et est inscrite à
la St Paul Girl's School, l'une des seules
écoles de Londres qui enseigne la physique
et la chimie aux jeunes filles.
Elle apprend aussi le latin et le français,
et obtient une bourse universitaire en 1938.
Elle entre donc dans l'un des collèges de
Cambridge, mais pas n'importe comment.
À l'époque Cambridge ne compte que 10% de
femmes qui ne sont que tolérées: elles
peuvent suivre les cours, mais seulement rassemblées
entre femmes au premier rang.
Elles peuvent passer leurs examens, mais n'obtiennent
pas de diplôme.
Elles ne sont même pas appelées Miss, mais
«Sir», comme les hommes.
Franklin poursuit ses études sans se révolter
contre cela: sa seule volonté est d'apprendre,
toujours apprendre.
Pendant la Seconde Guerre Mondiale elle travaille
sur le carbone, qui peut permettre de produire
des masques à gaz et des carburants.
Sa famille accueille de jeunes réfugiés
juifs fuyant l'Europe continentale, et Franklin
est garde dans l'Air Raid Precautions qui
s'assure de la surveillance et de la sécurité
durant les bombardements.
Le tout en rédigeant a thèse sur la porosité
du charbon, qu'elle soutient avec succès
en 1945.
Après l'obtention de son doctorat, elle entre
au Laboratoire central des services chimiques
de Paris pour se former à la cristallographie
aux rayons X.
Il s'agit d'une technique élaborée au début
du XXe siècle, consistant à bombarder un
échantillon avec des rayons X pour en tirer
une image.
La cristallographie était d'abord utilisée
sur des minéraux, comme le carbone sur lequel
elle travaille, avant d'être employée, puis
sur les hormones, les protéines et autres
molécules biologiques.
En France, elle est bien.
Marie Curie est passée par là, ça se sent,
Franklin est bien plus proche des scientifiques
français avec qui elle peut avoir des discussions
animées que des anglais feutrés et un peu
trop sexistes.
Pourtant elle retourne en Angleterre en 1951.
Elle est recrutée par le King's College de
Londres pour y étudier l'ADN par cristallographie.
Elle passe sous la direction de John Randall,
et a pour collègue Maurice Wilkins.
Wilkins et elle travaillant en parallèle
sur les même recherches, la situation se
tend rapidement, d'autant que les premiers
résultats de Franklin réfutent les théories
de Wilkins.
L'ADN est découvert en 1871, mais on ne connaît
pas encore son utilité ni sa structure.
On pense alors que ce sont les protéines,
aussi présentes dans les chromosomes, qui
sont à l'origine des caractères héréditaires.
Franklin parvient à distinguer les formes
A et B de l'ADN, et surtout elle réalise
le cliché 51 qui permet d'identifier la structure
en double hélice de l'ADN.
C'est une découverte majeure mais Franklin
ne s'empresse pas de publier à ce sujet:
elle est perfectionniste et recherche le meilleur
cliché, les meilleurs résultats avant de
proposer un modèle, sans réaliser que ses
collègues sont tous en pleine course à l'ADN.
Elle n'est pas du tout carriériste, contrairement
à Wilkins et à deux autres chercheurs de
Cambridge, Watson et Crick, dont on reparlera
très bientôt.
En attendant, l'ambiance reste mauvaise à
King's College.
Certains professeurs refusent que les femmes
mangent dans le même réfectoire que les
hommes, la plupart des clubs qui permettent
vie sociale et réseautage sont non mixtes,
Wilkins la considère comme une assistante
ou l'ignore...
À cause de cela, elle quitte King's College
en 1953 et doit laisser ses travaux sur l'ADN.
Elle rejoint le Birbeck College, où elle
applique ses travaux de cristallographie sur
les virus et permet la découverte de la structure
du virus de la mosaïque du tabac.
Elle collabore aussi avec des laboratoires
américains, et travaille sur le virus de
la poliomyélite.
Quelques mois après avoir quitté King's
College, son ancien supérieur l'appelle pour
lui ordonner d'arrêter de travailler sur
l'ADN.
Juste après, comme par hasard, un article
signé Watson et Crick paraît dans la revue
Nature, décrivant la structure en double
hélice de l'ADN.
Évidemment, elle n'est pas citée.
Il se trouve que Wilkins, son ancien collègue,
avait montré les clichés et les résultats
de Franklin à Watson et Crick après son
départ de King's College.
Watson et Crick travaillent à Cambridge mais
n'ont jamais fait une seule expérience de
cristallographie: ils prétendent avoir
établi un modèle de la structure de l'ADN
que le cliché 51 est venu confirmer, sans
citer les travaux de Rosalind Franklin, alors
que leur modèle est crée à partir du cliché.
Wilkins écrit à ce propos aux deux chercheurs:
«Vous êtes deux belles fripouilles mais
je crois que vous avez trouvé la clé».
Franklin ne se défend même pas puisqu'elle
ignore que Watson et Crick ont vu ses travaux.
Dans son livre La double hélice, paru en
1968, Watson ne dissimule pas vraiment ce
qu'il pense de Franklin: «J'étais plus
au courant de ses travaux qu'elle ne l'imaginait.
Plusieurs mois plus tôt, Wilkins m'avait
résumé la nature de ses prétendus résultats
anti hélicoïdaux.
Francis m'ayant assuré que c'était un veau
à cinq pattes, je décidai de risquer l'explosion.
Sans hésiter davantage, je répliquai qu'elle
n'était pas compétente pour interpréter
ces clichés.».
Ce n'est d'ailleurs pas que sur ses compétences
qu'il trouve des choses à redire: «Malgré
un visage volontaire, elle n'était pourtant
pas dépourvue de charme et aurait même pu
être séduisante si elle s'était ne fus-ce
qu'un tantinet préoccupée de son habillement.
Mais cela ne l'intéressait pas, pas la moindre
trace de rouge sur ses lèvres pour contraster
avec ses cheveux noirs bien tirés.
A 31 ans elle déployait en matière de robe
l’imagination ingrate d'un jeune bas-bleu
britannique». Il persiste aussi à l'appeler
Rosie, surnom qu'elle déteste et raison pour
laquelle j'ai décidé de ne l'appeler que
par son nom dans cet épisode.
Comme les scientifiques masculins.
En 1962, Wilkins, Watson et Crick reçoivent
le prix Nobel de médecine pour la découverte
de la structure à double hélice de l'ADN.
Franklin n'est citée que par Wilkins dans
les discours de remerciements, et ne peut
de toute façon pas se défendre non plus.
En 1956, on lui détecte un cancer des ovaires
probablement dû à son exposition aux rayons
X.
Elle subit une interdiction de travailler
mais c'est hors de question pour elle.
Elle met ses affaires en ordre, dresse un
compte-rendu de ses travaux, travaille jusqu'au
bout et meurt le 16 avril 1958.
Elle avait 37 ans.
De nombreux scientifiques, surtout des femmes,
meurent prématurément de cancer ou de leucémie
au cours du XXe siècle à cause de la méconnaissance
des dangers des rayons X.
«La mort prématurée tragique de Rosalind
est une grande perte pour la science.
A l'aide des techniques expérimentales et
mathématiques d'analyse aux rayons X les
plus ingénieuses, elle confirma et clarifia
l'hypothèse lumineuse de Watson et Crick
de la structure en double hélice de cette
substance.
Elle apporta la preuve irréfutable que la
principale chaîne de sucre et de phosphate
de l'acide nucléique est située à l'extérieur
et non à l'intérieur de l'hélice, ce qu'elle
avait suggéré avec certitude.»
Rosalind Franklin est donc l'une des nombreuses
femmes dont les expériences ou découvertes
ont été oubliées, effacées, prises de
haut par leurs collègues masculins.
Elle souffre de l'effet Matilda, théorisé
par Margaret Rossiter dans les années 80,
qui veut que les femmes scientifiques ne bénéficient
que très peu des retombées de leurs découvertes.
Dans les années 70, grâce à la montée
du féminisme en Angleterre, Franklin devient
une icône dans son pays.
On cherche à lui redonner sa place dans l'histoire
des sciences, l'article qu'elle allait publier
sur l'ADN paraît finalement en 1968 et une
biographie de sa vie sort en 1974.
Elle devient une figure féministe grâce
à son indépendance et à cause de la manière
dont elle a été traitée par ses collègues,
bien qu'on connaisse peu ses opinions sociales
ou politiques.
Franklin n'était peut-être pas féministe,
mais a plus que souffert du sexisme de son
milieu et de la société.
Depuis que son nom est sorti de l'oubli, de
nombreux hommages lui ont été rendus.
L'école dans laquelle elle avait étudié
la reconnaît comme l'une de ses élèves
les plus illustres, elle reçoit plusieurs
prix à titre posthume, et le futur rover
martien de l'Agence Spatiale Européenne sera
baptisé en son honneur.
Ce sera la première fois qu'un engin d'exploration
spatiale porte le nom d'une femme scientifique.
Quarante ans après sa mort, Watson et Crick
admettent enfin qu'ils n'auraient jamais complété
leur modèle et obtenu le prix Nobel sans
les travaux de Rosalind Franklin.
«tu affirmes fréquemment et semble insinuer
dans ta dernière lettre que j'ai développé
une vision totalement partiale des choses,
et que j'examine et réfléchis sur tout à
la lueur de la science.
Il est évident que ma façon de penser et
de raisonner est influencée par ma formation
scientifique, si cela n'était pas le cas
les études que j'ai suivies auraient été
une perte de temps et un échec.
Mais tu sembles considérer la science, ou
du moins c'est ainsi que tu en parles, comme
une invention humaine qui peut nuire à la
morale, qui est sans rapport avec la vie réelle,
une invention qui doit être soigneusement
écartée de la vie quotidienne.
Mais la science et la vie quotidienne ne peuvent
et ne doivent pas être cloisonnées.
Selon moi, la science fournit une explication
partielle de la vie.»
Comme je vous le disais en début de vidéo,
Rosalind Franklin figure dans les 250 cartes
du jeu de société féministe Bad Bitches
Only.
A la manière d’un Time’s Up, le but est
de faire deviner un maximum de cartes à son
équipe, en mots, mimes ou dessins selon les
manches.
Parmi les femmes citées dans le jeu, on y
retrouve autant des scientifiques, que des
artistes, des femmes politiques ou encore
des sportives.
L’idée est de lutter contre l’invisibilisation
des femmes et de leur redonner la place qu’elles
méritent!
On y retrouve autant des figures très connues
– comme Madonna ou Cléopâtre – que d’autres
qui ont été oubliées de l’Histoire, comme
Rosalind Franklin.
Pour découvrir qui sont ces dernières, un
petit livret, le Bad Dico, est inclus dans
la boîte et décrit en quelques lignes qui
elles sont.
Comme ça, vous pourrez vous améliorer de
partie en partie et vous refaire une culture
féministe! Pour l'avoir testé avec une
pote plutôt calée culture actuelle et musicale,
et moi plutôt forte niveau histoire, étonnamment,
c'était très sympa, facile à jouer, et
on a toutes les deux fait pas mal de belles
découvertes.
Vous pouvez commander le jeu directement sur
le site internet qui s’affiche, dont vous
retrouverez également le lien en commentaire.
Merci d'avoir suivi cet épisode, j'espère
qu'il vous a plu, et rendez-vous la prochaine
fois pour du Chroniques de Prof!